dvd disques vinyles la boutique mur au
disque offre à ses clients un flash back
à travers les décennies voire des
siècles
quand vous venez dans notre boutique
vous fait effectivement un retour en
arrière mais vous avez je dirais le
sentiment de trouver des choses qui
satisfont tout le monde jeunes moins
jeunes ancien mais toujours avec la même
fibre de trouver je dirais une petite
pépite de beethoven à elvis presley en
passant par les classiques de la chanson
française
chacun peut y trouver son compte avec
même certaines pièces plus original
exemple nous avons un angle firent qui
est le roi de la flûte de pan
donc il faut aimer mes dédicaces et
chose quand même à peu près unique
atahualpa yupanqui qui est très connu
aussi sur la musique des angles en tout
ce sont 1600 vinyles et autres produits
reçus pour la plupart de la ressourcerie
des quevilly ce chantier d'insertion qui
récupère du matériel ancien et porteur
du projet mur au disque est la
ressourcerie on reçoit beaucoup de
matériel dvd vinyles et on a pensé que
ça pouvait être l'occasion de créer un
emploi est aussi un peu le défi c'était
de se dire est-ce qu'on arriverait à
faire venir les gens aux mureaux
voilà de tous les villages autour un
local partagé avec cinq autres boutiques
et des meubles en carton sur mesure la
boutique pourrait se pérenniser en cas
de succès c'est en fait une une boutique
éphémère donc on est au sein d'un projet
plus grands qui accueille d'autres
porteurs de projets on est là
normalement pour six mois et ça permet
de faire le test de vérifier la
faisabilité et si ça marche ensuite
d'avoir une vraie boutique un peu plus
grande encore pour pour avancer en
attendant de savoir si le modèle
économique est viable marc le disquaire
continuera de faire tourner ses disques
jusqu'à l'hiver